auf der venus könnte eines der größten
rätsel der wissenschaft gelöst werden
und das raumschiff namens brice wäre
dazu in der lage sich solar betrieben
und hat bewegliche flügel die nasa hat
jetzt dieses unbemannte raumschiff in
ihr förderprogramm aufgenommen es geht
darum zu klären ob es genug zeit auf der
venus gab um leben entstehen zu lassen
pixum science fiction hier gibt's dem
gespann des seins videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nicht los geht's recht
bekommen die venus kann man sich
vorstellen wie eine echte höllen
landschaft hier herrscht eine
durchschnittstemperatur von rund 460
grad celsius sodass es heiß genug wäre
um leid zu schmelzen die atmosphäre des
planeten besteht zum größten teil aus
kohlendioxid und ist zudem extrem dicht
so herrscht auf der venus eindruck der
auf der erde und in 900 metern unter
wasser zu finden ist die nasa beschreibt
dem planeten als eine dunkle welt mit
intensiver hitze und vulkanischer
aktivität zudem ist hier eine so
genannte retrograden rotation zu
beobachten im klartext heißt das dass
sich der planet im vergleich zu unserer
erde in die entgegen gesetzte richtung
dreht doch nicht nur das die venus dreht
sich nicht nur verkehrt herum sondern
auch mit einer extrem langsamen
drehgeschwindigkeit um sich einmal um
sich selbst zu drehen also was bei uns
ein tag ist braucht der planet 2 143
tage
und weil der planet näher an der sonne
dran ist dauert ein jahr auf der venus
kürzer nämlich 225 erdentage das
ergebnis dieses phänomens große teile
des planeten liegen für lange zeiträume
im dunkeln was die erforschung des
planeten der vergangenheit kompliziert
gemacht hatte denn die meisten sonden
oder rover sind ja auf das sonnenlicht
angewiesen um mit hilfe von solarenergie
voran zu kommen
fest steht jedenfalls die venus wurde
lange von der forschung vernachlässigt
doch das ändert sich gerade die nasa
möchte ab dem jahr 2025 mit ausgewählten
missionen zur venus fliegen und hat
dafür förderprogramme gestartet mit
dabei ein projekt der universität
buffalo hat ein forschungsteam einem
rochen raumschiff mit dem namen brice
entwickelt die komplette bezeichnung bio
inspired rey vor extreme
moment seine explorations erinnert wegen
seiner flügel an einen stachelrochen der
durch das wasser gleitet doch das
raumschiff soll sich natürlich nicht
durch wasser bewegen sondern die dunkle
seite der venus erkunden der plan sieht
vor dass brice den planeten alle vier
bis sechs tage umrundet und somit immer
rechtzeitig mit den solarzellen seine
akkus aufladen kann demnach wäre die
sonde alle zwei bis drei tage auf der
sonnenseite der venus doch die winde in
der oberen atmosphäre der venus sollen
ausgenutzt werden um voranzukommen
genau deswegen auch die konstruktion der
flügel die eine exakte steuerung des
raumschiffes ermöglichen sollen
das ist enorm wichtig um potenziellen
gefahrenzonen auszuweichen und das
raumschiff beispielsweise vor wolken aus
schwefelsäure zu schützen dazu einer der
beteiligten wissenschaftler david
bayern-tor wir haben uns den natur zum
vorbild genommen vor allem am
stachelrochen haben wir uns orientiert
so wollen wir die flug effizienz
maximieren das design wird ein bisher
unerreichtes maß an kontrolle über ein
solches raumfahrzeug ermöglichen das ja
sehr extremen winden auf dem planeten
ausgesetzt wäre die mission soll
spannende erkenntnisse zur venus liefern
unter anderem zu ihrer atmosphäre dem
vulkanischen aktivitäten und dem
wettermuster die nasa tüftelt außerdem
an einem konzept für ein bemanntes
luftschiff das über den schwefel wolken
der venus fliegen könnte der name high
altitude wieners operational konzept
havok beide nasa projekte sind noch
längst nicht ausgereift und werden
sicherlich noch einige jahre arbeit in
anspruch nehmen schon in vier jahren
2023 allerdings möchte die indian space
research organisation csiro einen
orbiter zur venus starten und auch die
europäische weltraumorganisation esa und
die russische weltraumagentur roskosmos
haben die venus im visier und das
steigende interesse hat einen grund
nicht wenige forschende sind davon
überzeugt dass sie hier eines der großen
rätsel der wissenschaft lösen könnten
was genau macht einen planeten bewohnbar
erst vor kurzem hatten expertinnen
experten herausgefunden dass die venus
in der vergangenheit mal ganz anders
ausgesehen haben muss als heutzutage vor
vielen jahren war sie wohl von sich in
vielen jahren war sie wohl sogar mal mit
ozean bedeckt und somit vielleicht sogar
bewohnbar der planet hat sich wohl stück
für stück zu der heutigen höllen
landschaft entwickelt und so werden
derzeit
mit hochdruck technologien entwickelt
die in den schrecklichen bedingungen auf
der venus trotzen könnten falls einige
der vorstand aber recht behalten sollten
und die venus tatsächlich einmal drei
milliarden jahre lang wie die erde aus
gesehen hat ist auch eine sache ganz
klar die evolution hat die genug zeit in
aktion zu treten
genügend zeit also für die entstehung
von leben die zweite erde venus früher
mehr zum thema bei astro comics tv
anklicken anschauen und us comics tv
abonnieren sehr cooler kanal bis dann
bleibt dran